Speaker 1: The Georgia Senate runoff has gone
completely off the rails as Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker has accused Rafal
Warnock of sexual assault and physical assault.
What?
What is he talking about?
None of us know.
And increasingly the question is being asked.
Does Walker even have any idea what he's talking
about?
Is this defamation?
Let's look at the clip.
This is you know, to say it's gotten ugly
is an understatement.
I genuinely don't know whether Walker has
any idea what he's saying, but that would
not be an excuse here.
That would not be an excuse.
This is the height of dangerous irresponsibility.
Herschel Walker spoke yesterday at some event.
He's doing these campaign events all over
Georgia.
And he said, you know, there was physical
abuse and there was sexual abuse.
Who did it?
It has to be Senator Raphael Warnock.
Now, I'll tell you what this relates to in
a moment.
Here's the clip.
Speaker 2: He's not what do you think it's
going to be?
It's only the best people that know him best.
Say that he's an actor.
He's an actor.
I don't know what he did at that camp as well.
Y'all may not have heard this.
This young man said it was a sexual abuse.
That was physical abuse.
Somebody who did that.
It had to be Senator Raphael Warnock because
he's responsible for it.
You ought to hear about that.
Did you he don't want to talk about those
things because he don't want you to know that
he think you're going to be he gets a good
senator for you.
I'll tell you right now, it is time for a
change.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now, if you can make heads or tails out of
that unintelligible word salad, by all means,
go ahead and do it.
This is so difficult because Walker clearly
is saying that Raphael Warnock sexually abused
and physically abused a kid.
It's clear that he's saying those words, but
at the same time, it's never really clear
that Walker has any idea what he's saying.
And I know every time we talk about this oh,
David.
Well, that's not really issues oriented or
he has a brain injury from football that hasn't
been said, or this is because of his dissociative
identity disorder that he says these things.
That's not the explanation that they're giving.
We have to go by what he is saying.
And there's a real question as to whether
this is potentially defamatory.
Now, again, it's not clear Walker knows what
he's saying because it's never clear he knows
what he's saying.
But what this is about relates to allegations
that camp counselors 20 years ago at a camp
were Warnock.
Warnock ran the camp, but there's no allegations
that Warnock did any of this stuff.
The allegation is that a 12 year old boy was
forced to sleep outside at the camp and had
urine tossed on him by camp counselors.
Okay.
Absolutely horrible allegations.
And the incident was investigated in 2000
122.
It resulted in no charges.
Law enforcement later called it a miscommunication
and it was never even alleged that Warnock
did any of this stuff.
Now, you could say, well, if indeed it happened,
maybe Raphael Warnock, who was running the
camp, had some ultimate responsibility.
But the idea that Warnock is a sexual or physical
abuser is completely out of this world.
Now the question then becomes, is this defamatory?
Because in general, you know, if some random
person on Twitter with five followers tweets
that Raphael Warnock sexually and physically
abused someone.
It's not defamatory because it's not damaging
to Warnock.
But when we look at the requirements for defamation,
the information that is allegedly defamatory
must be published.
Well, that means that it's public.
And here is the video.
We looked at the video.
So it certainly meets that standard.
The person being defamed was clearly identified
by the statement.
Meaning is it clear that Walker is talking
about his opponent?
Senator Raphael Warnock I would argue it's
clear that that is, he says.
Raphael Warnock is the one who did this.
There's no confusion as to whether he means
someone else by that name or anything like
that.
Number three, the remarks have a negative
effect on the person's reputation.
That's the question.
We don't know yet.
But if it starts to spread in such a tight
race, the completely baseless allegation that
Warnock is a physical and sexual abuse, or
you could argue that those remarks have a
negative impact on Warnock's reputation.
Number four is, is the information demonstrably
false?
Well, it's hard to prove negatives, but there's
certainly no evidence that these allegations
about Warnock are true.
And the police investigation generally into
this incident at the camp, which isn't even
alleged to be warnock's doing found no legal
wrongdoing, and it didn't even allege that
Warnock was the one doing it.
And then number five, the defendant is at
fault.
In other words, that it is indeed Herschel
Walker, who made made these claims and made
them in a way that is consistent with with
reckless disregard or there's different different
standards in different states.
You arguably have a defamation case here.
Now, what I care more about is can we just
get Raphael Warnock over the finish line before
some new thing comes up that gets in the way
of this campaign?
And I think, again, without defending or attacking
the individual incident and what supposedly
happened to this 12 year old, what Walker
said is not even remotely based, in fact,
than the crowd just sort of goes along with
it.
The real disturbing part of all of this is
that this race even went to a runoff.
That's really the disturbing part that the
Georgia voters, Georgia Republican voters,
and this is a theme that we are following
in their desperation to not vote for a Democrat.
They are voting for someone who is completely
unqualified, doesn't have a sensible position
that he can articulate on any issue and on
a personal level is a complete hypocrite with
regard to the policy positions that he sort
of claims to advocate to the extent that we
can understand him completely against abortion,
in all cases, no exception.
Well, he urged two women and paid for two
women to get abortions.
Says we need we need men not to be absent
fathers.
He's an absent father to multiple kids that
we know about.
It's not even totally clear to me how many
kids it is, and on and on and on.
That alone is not a reason to vote against
him.
But the totality of the situation should lead
to this guy losing by 40 points.
And instead it was so close within one point,
with neither candidate able to secure 50%
of the vote that now we have a runoff on December
6th.
Let's really hope that our Georgia friends
who vote in Georgia get out there and make
this extraordinarily important vote.
We'll have live coverage on December six.
That's the day of the runoff